so we have an ascendancy class to
announce through GameSpot specifically
and that's the juggernaut which is a
specialization of the Marauder and so if
you wanna bring up the passive tree for
the juggernaut so this is the class he
and other juggernaut as the designers
back home call it is what happens when
you combine the unstoppable force with
the a movable objects this is a combat
class that wants to get in combat stay
in combat and be very hard to kill and
so he's got a bunch of interesting
passives here an example is unstoppable
another stops you from being slowed down
and that's really really relevant
because there's so much stuff in path of
Exile now which tries to weaken you by
making you slower because of course if
you're slower you're more prone to being
attacked by monsters you know this tower
on the ground this freezing there's
chilling those traps there's all this
kind of stuff so Jonathan's also
allocated undeniable now there's a
massive increase to attack speed and
accuracy racing once you're in combat
you're just a killing machine with us
and there's a bunch of other interesting
scripts tilts skills that we can also
discuss here this particular
specialization with four points includes
both of those so Joe and try some combat
with the juggernaut now compared to the
other Marauder classes the
specialization here is for players who
really want to be tanky it's one built
around defenses which will be especially
appealing to hardcore users because they
want to do everything they can to make
sure that they you know have a little
bit more of an edge against the game in
terms of not dying and so this is a
classroom you know the environment is
not going to slow you down you know that
you're going to be able to get into
combat and pack-a-punch regenerate your
way through it and as long as you're in
combat you're probably going to be okay
it's certainly not a particularly
tactical class you want to just be on
the frontlines and fighting
so the area that Jonathan is playing in
here is one that as a bunch of cold
monsters now the reason that we've
specialized we've picked this area is to
show the fact that if Jonathan gets
chilled or frozen while he's fighting
them it doesn't matter he doesn't slow
down for any other class if you become
frozen you're like a block of ice you
can't move and you're completely
vulnerable for several seconds relying
on RNG firstly give transit yeah but
either way if Jonathan is frozen he's
basically a block of ice that can
continue to attack and pass with no
penalty
yeah so he's basically completely
impervious to the cold damages being
thrown around there and so this is the
kind of character class that's really
good from people that just wants an
uncomplicated melee experience whether
in the front lines are not hampered by
the things the monsters are doing
against them while increasing the speed
and so on massively but you wanna go
back to the passive tree after you've
dealt with this monster yet and we'll
discuss some of the other passives there
now it's worth noting that he briefly
got the fortify buff there due to the
fact that he has a support of most
support gem so unyielding here means
that you have additional damage while
fortify and this is something the
character conditionally gets due to a
support gem that it has it also gives
you a bunch of life regeneration now
it's likely that the juggernaut is
triggering fortified really often
because it stays in combat there's also
some very interesting nodes that deal
with endurance charges on this character
so typically endurance charges are
things you can get under various
conditions but here you get a chance to
get one every time you hit now because
this character is getting hit constantly
due to being a juggernaut it's
triggering a lot of insurance endurance
charges this is very relevant because
some builds really want to get and
maintain a lot of endurance judges and
other ones just want to happen because
they provide big bonuses and the final
skill the deals will have current
charges that this character has is one
that just powers them up a massive
amount and increasing your resistance is
and so on when you get them and that
means you can kind of go all-in on
insurance charges using skills like
enduring cry an immortal call and really
synergizing now this is the level of
depth or that particular type of charge
that wasn't possible in topics on before
whether the juggernaut is one of the
three different ways you can play path
of Exile ascendency is coming out in
early 2016 for more information please
check out path of Exile comm slash
ascendency and we're looking forward to
posting a bunch of news updates over the
next few months so you can see how its
development is continuing and hopefully
get a chance to play it for yourself
you